na je passe tout de suite à notre second
débat sur la campagne présidentielle
impacté par la crise sanitaire comment
mener une campagne en pleine crise covin
faut-il adapter les règles du vote pour
limiter le risque d'abstention si
l'épidémie toujours aussi forte dans
trois mois demain demain le premier
ministre réunit en visioconférence les
chefs de partis pour évoquer les pistes
de réflexion sur ces thèmes sandra
cerqueira
le gouvernement rencontrera demain les
candidats pour examiner les modalités
d'organisation de la présidentielle
succo vide le vote par procuration
devrait être facilitée mais pour le
sénateur eric kerrouche cette mesure est
insuffisante
le vote par anticipation sur les trois
jours précédant le scrutin est selon lui
une piste plus intéressante quand on
veut sur les trois jours avant le
scrutin c'est-à-dire le vendredi le
samedi et le dimanche on régule tout
simplement le flux en faisant voter sur
ces trois jours au lieu qu'il y ait une
concentration uniquement sur le dimanche
l'idée c'est encore une fois de trouver
des modalités d'une part qui permettent
de répondre à la pandémie ça c'est vrai
mais d'autre part des modalités aussi
qui permettent tout simplement de rendre
le jeu plus facile en février dernier le
gouvernement a tenté de faire passer le
vote par anticipation pour la
présidentielle via des machines à voter
un amendement rejeté par les sénateurs
qui pointait alors l'obsolescence des
machines où l'incertitude sur les dates
fixées pour le sénateur stéphane le
rudulier les pistes du vote par
correspondance ou du vote électronique
ne doivent pas être écartée mais pas
pour la présidentielle ces modalités de
votre que ce soit le vote par
correspondance que ça soit le vote
électronique
doivent être éprouvée sur des scrutins
beaucoup moins cruciaux que l'élection
présidentielle pour qu'on puisse faire
un retour d'expérience sur ce qui
fonctionne il est plus facile d'avoir
autour expérience sur un un scrutin par
exemple municipal dans un périmètre
donné sur un département données pourra
préfère une généralisation
seule certitude
l'idée de repousser le scrutin si la
crise sanitaire perdure à d'ores et déjà
été écartée par l'exécutif car la durée
du mandat du chef de l'état élu pour
cinq ans est inscrite dans la
constitution
un tel report nécessiterait une révision
constitutionnelle
impossible à trois mois de l'élection
allons vivre une campagne présidentielle
sous cloche c'est le thème de notre
débat et je vous présente mes invités
mots de brison bon soit il ya venu vous
êtes porte parole de la république en
marche hervé marseille monsois je fais
nateur des hauts-de-seine président du
groupe union centriste au sénat bruno
cautrès bonsoir soit professeur à
sciences po chercheur cnrs au cevipof
avec nous en duplex manuel bompard
député européen et directeur de campagne
de jean luc mélenchon bonsoir bienvenue
à vous aussi matthieu croissandeau est
resté à mes côtés évidemment alors on
est en pleine actualité puisque demain
le pré ministre jean castex reçoit les
enfin réunis en visioconférence pour
être précis les les chefs de parti ruth
brégeon d'état trois mois jour pour jour
du premier tour de la de la
présidentielle est ce que finalement
cette proximité là ça ne limite pas la
marge de manoeuvre pour faire évoluer le
les règles de de ce scrutin et de la
campagne elle même c'est la limite
forcément partie ssrt est toujours plus
simple si on avait cinq ans devant nous
mais en tout état de cause on s'adapte à
une situation sanitaire qui évolue et le
président de la république l'a rappelé
il fera tout pour que la campagne
présidentielle puisse se dérouler de la
façon la plus normal que ce soit il n'y
a pas eu de jauge imposé pour les
meetings on y reviendra peut-être que le
conseil constitutionnel ne le permet pas
pour autant il ya une volonté de
l'exécutif du gouvernement de mettre
tout le monde autour de la table pour
réfléchir ensemble à ce qui est possible
de faire et puis un certain nombre de
dispositions qui seront reconduites on
pourra faire une procuration par exemple
par internet c'est 300 milles qui avait
été fait lors des élections régionales
donc ça montre que c'est quelque chose
qui fonctionne bien ça facilite ce
dispositif là il y aura du plexiglas
dans les bureaux de vote du gel qui
seront fournis pour permettre de
sécuriser le vote quoique on avait
remarqué lors des élections régionales
que c'était pas des clusters qui s'était
avéré après d après les élections donc
tout est mis en oeuvre pour faciliter sa
et pour miser sur la concertation avec
les différents candidats ou les
différentes organisations politiques à
marseille et est ce que vous attendez de
cette réunion demain bas à l'écouté pas
grand chose parce que il ya un peu
d'imprévoyance dans tout ça
on avait un peu patiné au moment des
élections municipales dire que c'est un
peu normal parce que on venait de tomber
face à ce problème pandémique mais on
avait mis au point des dispositifs
sur les conseils d'ailleurs du conseil
scientifique pour les départementales et
régionales par exemple
dédoublement des procurations
possibilité de dédoubler les les bureaux
de vote etc la difficulté c'est que
effectivement votre région vient de le
dire on est à moins de trois mois on a
moins de 100 jours de l'élection
l'assemblée nationale arrête ses travaux
fin février et pour toucher à tous ces
dispositifs faut plus simplement des
amendements faut une loi organique près
parce qu'on touche aux présidentielles
c'est pas n'importe quel ans que c'est
trop tard non il n'est pas trop tard
alors il faut que le gouvernement après
ces concertations prennent rapidement
des dispositions pour qu'on puisse au
moins faire ça on revenir à ce qu'on a
fait pour aux régionales sinon je vois
pas très bien comment sera pouvoir
marcher bon encontrais c'est quoi
l'enjeu pour l'exécutif selon ben déjà
lors jeu c'est de ne pas rater ce grand
des aux citoyens de la présidentielle il
ya de multiples signes qui montrent que
par rapport à ce qu'on 40 constatée il
ya cinq ans il ya un peu moins d'intérêt
pour la campagne présidentielle il ya un
peu moins de suivi la campagne
présidentielle il ya plus d'incertitudes
sur les choix de vote le sentiment aussi
un peu un peu diffus qu'on ne voit pas
très clair que c'est un peu opaque ls
quels sont les grands enjeux qui ceux
qui ceux qui se posent sont un peu et
comme on dit d'ailleurs par leur taille
et par là par la crise et ça c'est un
enjeu parce qu'au fond quel que soit
celui ou celle qui sera élue en 2022
l'enjeu principal c'est quand même de
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre son programme
sur la base d'un débat national
clairement que la moselle il ya quand
même aussi un enjeu de transparence
autour des règles de transcrit l'opinion
publique
au-delà de l'enjeu de transparence il ya
un enjeu au fond on a vu la
problématique de l'abstention augmenter
au fur et à mesure des dernières
élections en france dès les élections
municipales de mars 2001 déjà beaucoup
de personnalités politiques disent il
faut réfléchir
le vote par correspondance tout retour
peut-être le vote électronique on sait
que c'est compliqué du côté du vote
électronique
les algorithmes qui permettent de
sécuriser totalement ne sont pas prêt il
ya des équipes de mathématiciens du cnrs
qui travaille là dessus c'est un peu
compliqué quand même pour le moment le
vote électronique à distance on y
reviendra en détail douala alors mais
mais mais c'est vrai qu'un enjeu en
toile de fond qui est quand même de
réussir un peu une modernisation de
notre vie démocratique
et qu'on puisse au minimum répondre à
une partie de l'abstention qui est
l'abstention pour des raisons de
circonstance et des gens qui bossent le
dimanche et des gens qui travaillent
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche et
donc il ya des problèmes très pratiques
posés on n'a pas beaucoup avancé on n'a
pas beaucoup avancé on va détailler un
peu ce que vous avez les uns et les
autres évoqué est proposé mais je
voudrais et je vais vous donner la
parole juste après manuel m'ont pas
écouté jean luc mélenchon s'étaient cet
après-midi-là donner une conférence de
presse en amont de la réunion qui est
prévue demain à matignon le candidat de
la france a soumises et alors c'est
intéressant il demande que les dépenses
liées aux covin soit sorti des comptes
de campagne on écoute
quand vous déclarez vos comptes de
campagne vous devez absolument tout
déclaré c'est pas vous qui décidez ce
qui est remboursable ou pas augmenter ce
plafond pourquoi parce qu'il ya des
dépenses supplémentaires pour les
meetings nous allons fournir
gratuitement des masques ffp2 si nous en
trouvons en quantité suffisante mais si
par hasard nous nourrit ce qu'ils ont à
dire à quelqu'un nous voulons vérifier
ton pass sanitaires la personne en
question pourrait porter plainte contre
nous pour abus de pouvoir alors dans ces
conditions
il faut augmenter le moyen pour nous
deux pour pouvoir rembourser ses marques
ces masques ce type de masque réduit de
quasiment presque 100% la possibilité
d'être contaminés pour quand deux
personnes se trouvant face à l'une de
l'autre et qu'elles restent plus d'une
heure ensemble et un face-à-face bon
donc on voit que c'est un moyen
extrêmement efficace et le moyen proposé
par jean luc mélenchon notamment pour
garder une jauge pleine lors de ses
meetings on tient des on va en parler
avec avec ma mère mon père mais d'abord
manuel bompas vous étiez juste à côté de
jean luc mélenchon a lors de cette
conférence de presse est-ce que vous
avez value estimée ce que le coup vide
va où pourrait vous coûter dans cette
campagne
pas encore tout à fait parce que c'est
malheureusement très difficile à faire
parce qu'il ya les coûts directs donc
les coûts directs c'est typiquement les
dispositifs qu'on met en place en plus
de ce qui est exigé par la loi pour
faire en sorte que tout le monde puisse
participer par exemple le meeting dans
des bonnes conditions c'est ce dont
parlait jean luc mélenchon tout à
l'heure mais à des coûts qui sont un peu
plus caché par exemple nous on observe
que les prix des coûts de location des
salles pour organiser des meetings soit
parce qu'on doit prendre des salles plus
grandes pour faire en sorte que les gens
soient pas complètement entassés les uns
sur les autres soit tout simplement
parce que il ya beaucoup de salles où il
n'y a pas pu avoir d'événements pendant
un an ou deux ans donc les coûts sont
plus importants que ce qu'ils étaient
par exemple sur l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 et donc
effectivement il mes premières
propositions que l'on met sur la table
c'est de faire en sorte que le dmi
plafond en bourse à des frais de
campagne sont un peu plus important pour
que ces coups là puisse effectivement
être être remboursés bon on n'a pas fait
seulement cette proposition est un
add-on qu'on a mis sur la table le fait
par exemple de sécuriser les opérations
de vote en faisant en sorte que toutes
les personnes qui participent à la tenue
des bureaux de vote se voit accorder un
masques de type ffp2 qui sont des
masques qui protègent davantage et puis
pourquoi pas le fait qu'on utilise les
moyens numériques et audiovisuels pour
une campagne qui se passe dans des
bonnes conditions pourquoi pas augmenté
par exemple la durée le nombre des clips
de campagne qui sont vous savez toujours
dans la dernière ligne droite de la
campagne présidentielle puis pourquoi
pas jeudi cette dernière proposition
engagé des discussions avec les
plateformes numériques vous avez
aujourd'hui sur facebook des invitations
à aller se faire vacciner ou des
invitations à rester chez soi pendant
les périodes de confinement pourquoi on
ne pourrait pas utiliser ces mêmes
plateformes pour l'inviter à s'inscrire
sur les listes électorales ou pour
inviter à aller voter le jour du vote
voilà quelques-unes des propositions
qu'on a mis sur la pétition est très
concrète évidemment je reviendrai vers
vous à plusieurs reprises dans ce débat
évidemment
manuel bompas bruno cautrès sur le
plafond des dépenses de campagne c'est
faisable c'est simple ça ça demande ça
demande un texte particulier où je pense
qu'au delà du au delà du principe
pourquoi pas c'est peut être un élément
de discussion qui est pas qu'ils pas
inintéressant mais au delà de au delà de
ça je pense qu'il faut surtout que ça
soit assez fortement que le législateur
est l'occasion de se pencher sur la
question parce que dès qu'on touche aux
comptes de campagne pour les citoyens on
touche qu'à quelque chose qui peut
potentiellement être l'objet de beaucoup
de polémiques avant l'élection pendant
et après l'élection donc évidemment tout
ça doit être fortement très fortement
encadré c'est vrai que le plafond des
dépenses de campagne et quand même
conséquent en france en tout cas pour
l'élection l'élection présidentielle il
faudrait estimé quelle est la part des
dépenses qui sont liées effectivement
que vides est-ce que c'est marginal ou
est ce que ça représente pour tous les
candidats quelque chose de très
important mais en tout cas ça ne fait
pas de doute que si on toucher à ça du
point de vue du citoyen les lecteurs qui
regarde ça il faudrait beaucoup de
prudence
cette campagne elle est d'ores et déjà
évidemment impacté au parasite et
quelques informations sur le
l'adaptation concernant les meetings des
de certains des candidats par exemple
marine le pen son meeting de reims du 15
janvier qui a été décalé valérie
pécresse qui a dû annuler son meeting
d'investiture du 11 décembre qui était
prévu porte de versailles yannick jadot
anne hidalgo qui ont annoncé des
meetings restreint qui ont obtenu des
meetings restreint par dont les 11 et 12
décembre
mathieu elle est parasité par le la
situation sanitaire s'est les parasites
et de façon logistique on en a parlé
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
meetings qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
déplacements qu'est ce qu'on fera demain
dans les marchés si le virus on
connaissait une sixième bague est ce que
sarah dément est-ce qu'on donnera des
tracts et ce qu'on permettra aux gens
d'aller poster dans les boîtes aux
lettres toutes ces questions qui font
une campagne normale se poser puis elle
est aussi parasites et politiquement
j'allais le dire sur le fond à la
thématique la thématique qu'ovide
s'impose à tous en tout cas elle
s'impose à tous dans cette période là de
cinquième bague puisqu'on le voit les
débats au parlement sont consacrés à
l'extension dû faire la transformation
du passé sanitaires on passe vaccinale
ce qui fait plutôt les affaires du
pouvoir exécutif qui au fond ger ger la
crise et ça permet de ne pas parler
d'autre chose on voit bien que les
autres candidats pour le coup cherche
absolument à essayer d'imposer de
nouveaux thèmes de campagne vous l'a vu
la semaine dernière et valérie pécresse
et son karcher l'expression sarkozy pour
nettoyer les cités difficiles où eric
zemmour qui ne veut plus entendre parler
de covin qu'il faut parler d'autre chose
mais évidemment on a du mal à parler
d'autre chose parce que ce sujet
s'impose bonne région est ce que ça sert
l'exécutif finalement je pense que ça
sert absolument personne et que faut
rappeler avant tout que le coc vide n'a
pas d'agenda politique et qu'on subit
aujourd'hui la vendée me laissait
entendre que telle ou telle organisation
profiterait
de la situation sanitaire à quelque
chose je trouve dès que une analyse
extrêmement cynique ça pose des
difficultés ou en tout cas ça change la
façon de faire campagne pour l'ensemble
des organisations et je pense qu'il faut
aussi savoir s'adapter regarder les
dernières élections présidentielles aux
états unis il ya n'était en pleine
situation de sanitaires 100 le vaccin
donc beaucoup plus grave si je puis dire
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont réussi à
s'adapter au regard des commandes joe
biden comme donald trump ont réussi à
faire des meetings en extérieur dans les
parkings dans les stades de foot pharma
on a vu des images assez extraordinaire
assez incroyable je dis pas que c'est
forcément comme ça qu'il faut le faire
en france parce qu'on a des cultures
différentes mais c'est aussi en charge à
nous de savoir nous adapter et d'être un
petit peu créatif ya peut-être pas
qu'une seule façon de faire de la
politique ce n'est peut-être pas qu'une
seule façon de faire campagne je
voudrais rappeler dernièrement que quand
on fait un meeting dans un meeting on
convainc personne un meeting ça sert à
donner des soyons très clairs ça sert à
donner des images pour les médias et
pour la télévision donc et aussi tout un
travail de terrain qu'on peut faire même
en temps de pandémie parce
qu'aujourd'hui les gestes barrière le
masque du selmani on a un retour
d'expérience arts nous interrompre les
un meeting réussi un meeting marquant ça
peut faire une percée des idées qu'ils
diffusent des images position qui se
diffuse c'est aussi des personnalités
qui se révèle et si au site la
mobilisation et les meetings ils servent
parfois à rêver des personnalités ou à
montrer une forme de mobilisation vous
avez certaines personnes qui font des
très bonnes campagnes sont plutôt des
bêtes de meetings ou prenez jean luc
mélenchon qui n'est pas mort et même
s'ils connaissent souvent un coup de mou
en fin de campagne présidentielle mais
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui peut se
révéler dans une campagne il lui a tout
intérêt à ce que la campagne puisse
puisse se tenir et vous prenez d'autres
gens qui sont évidents - - - des bêtes
de meetings baisse a déjà légèrement et
alors ça pose la question des jauges
dans ses meetings vous propose d'écouter
ce qu'en disait le premier ministre
c'était le 27 décembre dernier jean
castex l'exercice du culte d'une part et
les activités politiques et électorales
d'autre part sont soumises à des
dispositions spécifiques dans notre
droit constitutionnel qui le rassure on
va dire une une protection encore plus
forte donc il est clair que les mesures
répondre à votre question que j'ai
annoncée ce soir ne concerne pas les
meetings politiques compte tenu de ses
spécificités
bon donc il n'ya pas de jauge pas
d'obligation de jauge lors des meetings
politiques mais ensuite les différents
candidats se sont positionnés on va
regarder comment ils s'adaptent
finalement est-ce qu'ils ont annoncé à
la fois sur la question des jauges mais
aussi la question du contrôle des passes
ou alors la question des masques on va
voir sa fiche et les différents
candidats et candidates d'anne hidalgo
qui dit oui aux trois propositions tout
comme bon la république en marche pour
l'instant on imagine que ce sera le
président de la république en fait ce
qui se différencie ce qui se différencie
c'est marine le pen qui refusent les
jauges et le système de pass sanitaires
à l'époque jean luc mélenchon même même
positionnement et zemmour eric zemmour
même conditionnement je joue à vous
entendre on part sur cette question
précise des meetings et des jauges
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
exactement
alors d'abord je voudrais juste vous
dire que non c'est pas le même
positionnement que les autres candidats
puisque nous bien sûr nous avons dit que
nous allons respecter la loi et donc
respecter la loi ça veut dire ne pas
impliquer de jauge sur les meetings et
ça veut dire aussi ne pas exiger la
présentation d'un pass sanitaires ou
d'un pass vaccinale si nous le faisions
et si nous étions amenés à interdire
l'entrée d'une personne parce qu'elle
n'avait pas son pass sanitaires ne sont
pas ceux maximale nous ne serions dans
une situation de désobéissance par
rapport à la loi et la personne pourrait
se retourner contre nous et nous
l'aurons choquer mais par contre nous
nous avons dit que nous allions sécurisé
en quelque sorte l'accès au meeting en
fournissant gratuitement des masques de
type ffp2 dont je disais tout à l'heure
qui protège davantage à l'ensemble des
participantes et des participants donc
c'est pas exactement le même
positionnement que les autres candidats
que vous avez cités tout à l'heure et je
voudrais dire ici qu'à partir du moment
où les dernières études disent que les
masques ffp2 réduisent quasiment d'un
facteur 100 les risques de contamination
par rapport à des masques traditionnels
il est moins dangereux de tenir un
meeting de 2200 personnes avec des
masques ffp2 qu'un meeting de 1800
personnes avec des masques traditionnels
et donc vous voyez chacun essaye de
france qu'on puisse organiser ces
initiatives mais tout en le faisant dans
le respect de la sécurité des gens qui
partent ici c'est notre préoccupation
est ce qu'ils se posent derrière c'est
la question de la responsabilité
d'hervé marseille comment vous évaluez
justement voilà lé là ce que vient de
dire à mannus le groupe ares ou
finalement là la situation et la prise
de position de marine le pen ou de houe
d'eric zemmour sur l'absence de jauge
dans leurs meetings et si vous pensez
que c'est pas suffisamment responsable à
écouter de toute façon le conseil
constitutionnel
ready
dit les choses on peut pas empêcher un
parti politique de faire des meetings et
de faire entrer qui veut à partir de
l'armée après est-ce qu'en plaine en
pleine vague gréau mikron qui est le
quand même on le rappelle pour l'instant
le plus contagieux d
des variants qu'on ait eu à affronter
est ce que ces responsables je repose la
question non mais à partir de là vous
avez aussi l'opinion parce qu'on voit
bien que les françaises et les français
ont du mal à comprendre que sous
prétexte que c'est un parti politique on
a droit de faire entrer en gros qui on
veut et autant qu'on veut vu la réaction
des artistes et voilà les artisans ibra
tiens je suis encore panier d'un
chanteur en fallait certes il faut des
sportifs etc encore que c'est encore
autre chose avec les jo je puisse me là
aussi on pourrait en parler c'est un peu
tout et n'importe quoi parce qu'on ya eu
deux jauges mais on met tout le monde
dans la dans la même tribune donc ça
change rien ça s'est passé lors d'un des
matches allant sur le coeur en revanche
du match suivant c'était mieux ouais en
revanche je crois qu'il faut il faut
revenir plus tôt aux conditions de
campagne la même façon qu'on parlait des
conditions de vote c'est l'accès aux
médias j'avais dire et des règles du csa
parce que ça c'est assez facile à
réorganiser et à partir du moment où on
est obligé d'avoir une campagne
complètement différente il faut qu'on
puisse avoir des concertations aussi
avec le csa pour modifier les règles de
prêt de présence sur les chaînes et les
radios
pour équilibrer et rendre les choses un
peu plus transparent vous rejoignez
finalement la proposition que faisait
manuellement par tout à l'heure sur plus
de présence médiatique c'est ce que
c'est ça il va falloir que de compenser
le
- de meetings ou moins de déplacements
qui va falloir évidemment monter les
curseurs fonction de la situation et on
est encore une fois à moins de 100 jours
donc on peut pas
prendre trop de temps pour préparer des
choses et donc à partir de là c'est
c'est maintenant qu'il faut prendre les
décisions et changer les règles de
présence sur les médias c'est quelque
chose qui peut se faire très rapidement
oui j'aimerais qu'on parle et on va
faire un focus précis sur le vote par
correspondance
je vous rappelle que demain à matignon
où il ya cette réunion il ya aussi
l'examen de la sur le pass vaccinale ici
au sénat et qu'on met à trois mois jour
pour jour du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle c'est l'une des pistes
est justement d'un style jourdain de me
rejoindre
des travaux de la commission des lois
sur le vote à distance le vote par
correspondance dans les pleins de bon
sens faut rappeler un peu ce que c'est
le vote à distance un thomas c'est le
recours au vote par procuration le vote
par internet ou effectivement encore le
vote par correspondance itou sur tous
ces outils par dont le sénat a lancé une
mission d'information c'était à l'hiver
2020 on est à quelques mois après le
début de la crise sanitaire les
sénateurs souhaitent réfléchir à la
manière d'éviter l'abstention aux
élections qui viennent on parle des
élections régionales et départementales
de juin 2021 à cette époque tout le
monde a en tête le cataclysme des
élections municipales rappelez-vous
deuxième tour du scrutin organisé au
mois de juin le taux de participation
n'avait été que de 41% thomas
effectivement c'est un mauvais souvenir
pour tous ceux qui aiment la politique
qu'est ce que le sénat avait préconisé
pour éviter cette abstention qu'on
redoute aussi pour cette présidence le
principe doit rester le vote dans
l'isoloir et goûter françois noël buffet
le président de la commission des lois à
l'époque nous avons tous considéré que
le principe du vote reste devait être le
vote dans l'ue par l'isoloir dans le
bureau de vote dans sa commune dans son
arrondissement dans sa ville et que cela
devait rester véritablement cette sorte
de rituel républicain qui est le nôtre
la base de notre système donc le vote
par internet le vote par correspondance
c'est non alors le vote par
correspondance et oui mais à certaines
conditions thomas le vote par
correspondance c'est un vote papier on
reste chez soi et on envoie le bulletin
par la poste une pratique qu'on connaît
plutôt bien en france puisqu'elle était
en vigueur entre 1946 et 1975 elle a été
suspendu à cause des fraudes constatées
mais on pourrait désormais mieux
sécuriser un tel scrutin selon les élus
sont les experts pourquoi pas donc mais
avant de le mettre en place ces
sénateurs proposent de l'expérimenté
afin de mieux le sécuriser le vote par
internet en revanche thomas c'est niet
françois noël buffet qui est toujours
président de la commission des lois nous
explique pourquoi écouter le jeu peu ça
pose un problème qui est celui d'avoir
une identité de numérique robuste or
nous ne l'avons pas encore les services
travaillent c'est avec angers des
services services de l'état travaillent
à cette identité numérique mais ça n'est
pas encore totalement sécurisé elle est
en préparation elle le sera
incontestablement mais pas dans le délai
qui nous intéresse en tous les cas pour
2021 voire même pour 2022 je ne crois
pas non plus voilà on n'était pas prêts
à l'hiver 2020 on n'est toujours pas
prêt aux gens pour le vote par internet
pourtant et bien rappelez vous c'était
une promesse du candidat maquereau en
2017 il promettait alors de généraliser
le vote électronique pour 2022 et oui
effectivement merci steve est justement
mathieu il ya eu une forme de
tergiversation de la part de l'exécutif
sur scène c'est assez sidérant quand on
y pense même impasse que l'on change pas
les règles du jeu quand la partie a
commencé je vois c'est sidérant qu'on se
pose maintenant la question de savoir
comment peut bien se dérouler cette
présidentielle faut-il réformer ou non
faut-il changer les modalités de vote
pourquoi pas cher c'est vrai qu'on a
l'habitude du vote physique en france
une même jour pour tout le monde à la
même date enfin voila on peut imaginer
peut-être que la société ayant évolué
que les gens ayant des métiers qui les
amène parfois à travailler le week-end
que certains certaines personnes
n'habitant pas je pense aux étudiants en
habitant pas forcément là où là où elles
soient inscrits sur les listes
électorales on pourrait développer ça
mais pourquoi le faire maintenant c'est
très étonnant d'autant plus que ça vient
d'être appelé emmanuel macron c'est vrai
c'était une promesse de 2017 nous avons
besoin de numériser notre démocratie en
instituant un vote électronique qui
élargira la participation réduira les
collections et modernisera l'image de la
politique cinq ans après il ya eu une
pandémie qui a gêné le scrutin municipal
qui lui a posé des questions et bousculé
la campagne pour les départementales et
régionales et a l'impression qu'on n'a
pas avancé rien de ce que ce soit sur le
vote électronique ne se soit sur l'autre
par croissance jugent leurs produits à
ce que dit le sénateur qui a pas de
d'identifiants numérique assez solide
aujourd'hui tous les contribuables qui
payent leurs impôts numériquement sont
très contents de l'apprendre
ça marche pour les enfants pourquoi ça
marche pas pour les autres pas non plus
haut calibre oui et puis c'est utiliser
aussi dans d'autres pays est ce que le
prénom à plus quatre simples en changer
d'avis en tout cas on sait pas mais en
tout cas il a tergiversé 1 parce que il
ya toute façon il na faire de contex en
france quand vous touchez aux modalités
de scrutin aux modalités de vote vous
êtes illico soupçonné de tripatouillage
et de volonté de tv land et dans les
allées serr autres débuts voilà il
aurait fallu le faire c'est simple c'est
vrai que ça existe en 15 pays d'europe
le vote par correspondance
les français sont pour quand on les
interroge quand on fait des sondages ils
sont plutôt tour il ya des forces
politiques qui sont pour françois bayrou
un allié du président qui l'a très
souvent réclamé jeudi la date il avait
réclamé pour les municipales la fois
dernière le problème c'est qu'il ya pas
eu d'organisation d'un débat serein sur
ce sujet a lancé l'exécutif le fait
aujourd'hui avec demain cette réunion
par visio-conférence jean castex que
c'est tard c'est vraiment très tard
d'autant que l'exécutif a aussi tendu
les verges pour se faire battre un peu
souvenez vous à part l'objet d'un
amendement au printemps dernier il ya eu
la possibilité de faire des votes par
anticipation qui était incrustée dans la
loi organique justement sur la plus
ancienne qui avait été retoquée par les
sénateurs jeudi qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire on n'est pas au courant
bref c'est dommage d'autant que c'est un
vrai sujet débat qui se créent y compris
des désaccords au sein de la majorité
vous prenez quelqu'un comme gérald
darmanin les poubelles tous favorables
il explique pourquoi avec un argument
qui peut s'entendre en tout cas qui est
que si on s'affranchit de l'isoloir et b
on est peut-être on remet le le doigt ou
en tout cas dans un vote sous influence
en sait si vous votez en famille qu'est
ce qui prouvera que on ne vote pas
forcément comme son conjoint ou comme le
peuple de dicter ses enfants pour les
ménages et écouter ou les communautés
aussi voilà bref c'est des questions
mais quel dommage quel dommage d'ouvrir
sa seulement à trois mois de campagne
vaudois jean toussaint dommage je dire
finalement ne pas le faire c'est ça veut
dire qu'on est pas suffisamment moderne
je sais pas si le vote a vocation à cet
argument
je termine je sais pas si le vote
forcément vocation à être quelque chose
de moderne c'est d'abord j'ai quelque
chose de solennel le fait de se déplacer
dans un bureau de vote d'aller dans un
isoloir de pouvoir voter en pleine
conscience sans avoir mon père mon cul
raymond à 20 qui me dit quoi va t il
parler des communautés mais c'est
vraiment un c'est un vrai sujet je pense
que ça ça compte sans savoir son mari
quand on est une femme qui puisse aussi
nous dire comment voter et puis enfin je
trouve que encore une fois dans cette
dans l'aspect solennel pour moi en tout
cas c'est quelque chose auquel je suis
attaché je considère qu'on élit pas un
président de la république comment votre
temps miss france mais enfin il ya
beaucoup d'autres pays européens qui le
font
et c'est terrible de voir qu'on ne peut
pas avoir un seul débat en france en
revenir sur cette question les
communautés etc il ya des trucs
extrêmement pratique affaire est
effectivement je le disais tout à
l'heure et les gens qui travaillent le
dimanche 6 à 20 30 ans il ya
pratiquement personne qui travaille le
dimanche aujourd'hui c'est une vraie
réalité socio-économique le royaume uni
qu'on veut pas soupçonner ne pas être
une grande démocratie parlementaire elle
permet le vote postal ils ont commencé à
faire du vote postal aux élections
européennes tellement le taux de
participation était faible il est arrivé
à moins d'un quart des britanniques qui
participaient aux élections européennes
dès la première année où ils ont fait du
vote postal +5 points de participation
dans les cinq circonscriptions
électorales où il l'avait testé donc à
un moment donné où effectivement ces
problématiques peut-être d'étalement du
vote il ya aussi d'autres pays européens
qui ont expérimenté le vote étalée sur
deux jours pour les gens qui travaillent
le dimanche vous voyez on pourrait voter
sur on n'arrive absolument pas ni à
avancer mais a progressé
alors que ces 15 min très pratique se
paye mais je reviens et avec nos
contrées sur la question du vote par
internet vous disiez tout à l'heure
c'est trop compliqué on travaille sur un
algorithme et on n'a pas dormi ou south
et utilise le moment il ya des
mathématiciens qui travaillent sur ces
questions et qui disent qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à l'absolue certitude qu'on ne
puisse pas fraudé ça qu'ils puissent pas
être hacké le vote le vote électronique
en france le choix avait été fait du
vote électronique aux bureaux de vote
ces terres l'urne électronique aux
bureaux de vote mais ça c'est un choix
qui avait été fait par français comme il
ya déjà 25 ou 30 ans mais c'est vrai que
c'est aussi une question sur laquelle on
va déboucher c'est à dire la solution
technique pour garantir l'absence de
fraude de nouveautés électroniques
arrivera manel bon par la solennité du
vote le passage par l'isoloir est ce que
vous rejoignez notre région est ce que
vous dites que c'est peut-être un peu
obsolète qu'il faut avancer quand même
ils n'ont de toute façon je crois
honnêtement la question se pose plus à
cette étape y compris on est dans une
situation quand même de défiance
dans le monde politique aujourd'hui qui
fait que la modification à trois mois du
scrutin des modalités du vote me
paraissait pas de nature à caen en sorte
que le scrutin se déroule de la manière
la plus apaisée possible ça nécessite
peut-être un débat qui effectivement se
fasse davantage en profondeur et plus
loin de la date de l'échéance moi je
veux juste dire une chose c'est la
première étape si on veut faire en sorte
que les gens aillent voter et les moins
de l'abstention c'est d'abord de
favoriser leur inscription sur les
listes électorales ça c'est pas très
compliqué à faire on a une date qu'est
le 4 mars qu'est la date limite de
clôture pour l'inscription sur les
listes électorales on parle pas de
quelques petit pourcentage de gens on
parle de plus de 25% aujourd'hui des
électrices et électeurs potentiels qui
sont soit non inscrits soit mal inscrits
sur les listes électorales et
honnêtement je déplore que sur ce sujet
le gouvernement ne mène et ne mette en
place aucune campagne non publique
d'annonce et d'incitation à s'inscrire
sur les listes électorales parce que là
déjà si vous faites en sorte que ces 25
% de gens soient bien inscrits sur les
listes électorales c'est 25% d'eau des
lectrices et des lecteurs potentiels
supplémentaires je pense que ce type de
solution serait à mon avis bien plus
adapté pour faire en sorte qu'on ait
davantage de participation que
d'inventer à trois mois du scrutin une
forme de vote à distance qui à mon avis
va créer les conflits et les
confrontations et ça me paraît pas de
nature à avoir un scrutin qui se déroule
dans des bonnes conditions ça je pense
qu'on est tous d'accord pour dire que
c'est trop tard pour lancer le vote par
internet sur les inscriptions sur les
listes électorales
jusqu'à un manque de volonté de la part
du gouvernement il y aura des campagnes
d'incitation à s'inscrire et à aller
voter juste moi ce que je voulais dire
c'est que je pense qu'il faut pas faire
l'erreur de circonscrire la question de
l'abstention
aux modalités logistique sur cette
question
je comprends qu'on en parle je comprends
qu'on débatte qu'on puisse réfléchir à
comment est ce qu'on le fait ou pas
évolué mais à mon avis si on a enfin
alors pressés aux études de le faire
mais lorsqu'on interroge les gens pour
savoir pourquoi est-ce qu'ils vont pas
voter je suis pas certaine que la
première réponse ce soit j'ai du mal à
m'inscrire où je retrouve pas à mon
bureau de vote où je travaille le
dimanche à mon avis à un vrai sujet de
confiance dans la queue ce qu'on appelle
la classe politique est déjà une
expression ce n'est pas très joli à
entendre pas très bien perçue dans la
tête des gens comment est-ce qu'on est
efficace comment est-ce qu'on change le
quotidien des gens à mohéli le vrai
sujet sur la question l'abstention il
est là bien plus que sur les modalités
techniques logistiques et bruno cautrès
et oui on est où tiens d'ailleurs ya un
vrai risque d'abstention record à 7
enfin de glace est vrai qu'il ya
plusieurs signes qui vont dans le sens
même moins d'intérêt qu'il y a qu il ya
cinq ans on le constate nous parce qu'on
fait un panel électorale au cevipof
sercel et même personne qu'on interroge
depuis maintenant 5 6 ans effectivement
on voit que le taux d'intérêt pour la
campagne présidentielle est plus bas
qu'il est exactement cinq ans alors
c'est vrai je rejoins ce qui a été dit
dans l'abstention il ya deux dimensions
très importante à la dimension vraiment
structurelles sociologique l'abstention
c'est d'abord et avant tout au fond la
sociologie des inégalités sociales ce
sont les catégories populaires ce sont
ceux qui manquent de ceux qui sont le
moins dotés en capital culturel qui
s'abstiennent le plus mais il ya une
part de l'abstention qui est la part
qu'on appelle circonstancielle ça les
gens qui ont effectivement des enfants
en bas âge de petit dernier qui est
malade le jour du vin évaluer c'est une
petite nuit c'est une petite part mais
elle existe et c'est vrai que cette
petite part l on pourrait faciliter
l'acte de vote l'autre part c'est la
mobilisation comme ça a été dit tout à
l'heure hervé marseille le groupe
centriste va profiter l'examen du texte
sur le pass vaccinale demain et mercredi
pour déposer des amendements lequel pour
vous et le plus emblématique ou plus
important jeu comme je voulais dit on
peut difficilement faire bouger le texte
puisqu'il faudrait faire quelque chose
de nature organique on va simplement
pouvoir évoquer le sujet attirer
l'attention du gouvernement et dire il
faut faire quelque chose il en a encore
le temps on va surtout parler
des modifications susceptibles
d'intervenir sur les interventions dans
les médias
avec le csa met tout ce que nous venons
dire à l'instant en fait montre qu'il
faut un débat c'est pas leur faut un
débat apaisé le moment venu et puis il
faut un ensemble de mesures c'est pas
une seule mesure parce que les gens
peuvent avoir peur de l'aco vide et ne
pas aller voter si les circonstances
sont pas réunies les gens peuvent ne pas
aller voter parce qu'ils vont considérer
que le débat est pas intéressant qui ne
se reconnaissent pas etc etc donc en
fait c'est un ensemble de mesures il ya
le fait qu'il faut voir les modalités
d'inscription allait d'abord davantage
vers la réactivité le numérique parce
que les gens bougent beaucoup plus que
par le passé il faut voir le problème de
la propagande électorale
parce qu on en est toujours au papier il
ya beaucoup de gens qui sont attachés
notamment dans les campagnes
je sais bien chaque fois qu au parlement
toutes tendances confondues qu'on a dit
on va supprimer
la propagande avec la photo vous sur la
commode dans les fermes à tout le monde
se met à hurler en en touche à rien
parce qu' il vaut mieux laisser comme ça
c'est vrai qu'il va falloir en sortir
c'est pas simplement fait un problème
financier pour le ministère de
l'intérieur qui chaque année et c'est
devant de sa salade mais je veux dire il
faut arriver à faire quelque chose qui
soit un ensemble de mesures qui
permettent de moderniser et de faire en
sorte que les gens adhèrent davantage
notamment les jeunes puisque on voit
bien qu aux régionales la classe d'âge
18 25 ans n'a pas voté à 96 victimes
auraient donc on moralité ce qu on sera
tous d'accord pour dire que ça doit être
un chantier de des buts de manga est
l'un des but de kaka merci beaucoup à
tous d'avoir participé à cette émission
rappelle que demain sens public s'efface
pour diffuser en direct les débats sur
le pass vaccinale ici au sénat on se
retrouve mercredi à 18 heures et à 22
heures sur public sénat et puis le
rendez vous demain dans la matinale
oriane nancy ni reçoit geoffroy didier
reault députés lr directeur de la
communication de la campagne de valérie
pécresse bonne soirée à tous